okay i'm continuing this rant okay part
two
part two of if you get pregnant
ladies it's your own fault we're not
even gonna put this on the men anymore
it's a hundred percent on us
why okay why
y'all realize abstinence is an option
[Music]
i didn't say it was a fun option
you want a hundred percent guarantee you
don't get pregnant
abstinence
and if not okay
if abstinence isn't for you
there's a bajillion birth controls
iud
the pill
that thing they put in your arm
and all of y'all
accidentally get pregnant you know you
can only get pregnant
like three days a month statistically
there's like a high probability you'll
get pregnant
you can track your cycle oh my god and
then here's the other thing if i ever
got pregnant you know what i would say
it was my own damn fault
why
why can't we just
put it on us
why we gotta put it on the men
we're in control
we're 100 in control unless you get you
know i said that's that that's that's
not what i'm talking about that's the
the rarity
guys if you get pregnant it is your own
damn fault i'm tired of us putting this
on the men
you
you were the problem it was your fault
okay i'm done
that's the end that's the end of my my
rant